meanwhile it appears that one of joe's
other top agenda items will also be
blocked
democratic senators mansion and cinema
well they vowed to actually uphold one
principle and that would be the
legislative filibuster here with
reaction all this
south carolina senator lindsey graham
senator i would say today's vote
if 45 people in your body think it's
unconstitutional
to have a post-presidential impeachment
i would say that this trial is dead done
finished and a waste of our time and
money
well it's always been unconstitutional
in my view and it was ill-conceived
the one thing you haven't talked about i
think we should spend more time talking
about
is that the president of the united
states was impeached in 50 hours
without one witness being called and it
didn't have a lawyer
so one of the reasons we need to make
sure this thing never goes anywhere
is because i don't want to legitimize
the impeachment process
used in the house i think it's a danger
to democracy
in the presidency itself so what's going
to happen next this is a floor not a
ceiling on the votes
to drop this case there'll be a motion
to dismiss
on day one of the trial i think we'll
get more than 45 votes once we hear
arguments about why it should be
dismissed and if we don't get 51 we'll
go to trial and i want your audience to
know the following
they never called a witness in the house
if there's an
effort by the democrats to call a single
witness
in the united states senate they had no
record in the house
there will be delay of this trial there
will be a pandora's box being opened
we will want witnesses and this thing
will go on for weeks if not months
so i'm hoping that we have a trial based
on
a stipulation of fact not witnesses and
we get this behind us
in about three days after we begin uh
why would the senate the united states
senate right they're supposed to be the
more
sober um body right of the two
why would they legitimize and validate
this you know snap impeachment as
jonathan turley calls it
that makes no sense to me um also
what about all the evidence uh from
investigators apparently even court
documents now showing
that in fact they believe that they
missed
all of the pre-planning that took place
well that totally contradicts the
narrative that this
what happened at the capitol was incited
by words of president trump and the
words of president trump actually mean
something to
peacefully patriotically march to let
your voices be heard
did we forget that part that was there
in the speech
that's what he was saying that day right
well the reason i know there's no
evidence of incitement that would
equal a crime by president trump is
they're not playing it
on those other networks have you seen
one clip
of president trump speaking where
somebody said this is a crime
the fact that there's no clip tells you
all you need to know
why are they doing this they're afraid i
think democratic senators are afraid of
the left wing of their party
that if they don't give some credibility
to this trial that started in the house
they're in trouble and joe biden's been
a huge disappointment thus far not only
on policy
but on the idea that i'm going to bring
the country together how easy would it
be
sean for joe biden to say it is bad to
impeach a president
after they leave office enough already
with donald trump let's look forward
so it tells you a lot about biden's
ability
and desire to bring us together by the
fact that he's sitting on the sidelines
and his only comment has been i don't
think they have the votes well
i'd like to put the same apply the same
standards to
maxine waters i'm going to take trump
out tonight
or that get in their faces create a
crowd did i want it anywhere anymore
follow him into the grocery store or
chuck schumer
on the steps of the supreme court
threatening gorsuch and kavanaugh
or kamala harris after a police precinct
was burned down
saying they're not going to stop they
shouldn't stop they won't stop
beware take no we won't stop uh is that
inciting
a crowd or paying for bail for arrested
rioters like she was part of a group
well that's legitimizing violence you're
actually trying to get people out of
jail
who burn down businesses and attack
police officers
and you openly saying they're not going
to stop they shouldn't stop
compare that to what president trump
said in his speech here's what i'd like
i'd like to get this trial over sooner
rather than later
to my democratic colleagues if you try
to call one witness
you're going to blow up the united
states senate don't do that let's get
this travesty over with
quickly all right i always criticize
republicans when they're weak when they
lack vision they don't have a backbone
45 republican senators killed
impeachment it is dead gone and buried
rest in peace great job to all of you
responsible thank you senator